[Musik]
das zdf heute live ganz herzlich
willkommen an diesem mittwochabend
jetzt geht es los ab montag impfen die
briten gegen das corona virus und zwar
mit dem rheinhessisch amerikanischen
impfstoff der firmen bei und heck und
pfizer damit ist das die erste zulassung
weltweit für diesen impfstoff es ist
zwar eine notfall zulassung aber es ist
eine zulassung
darüber sprechen wir heute abend und ich
freue mich sehr dass gemeinsam zu tun
mit unserem korrespondenten in london
andreas tangen danke andreas dass die
zeit für uns auf und wir freuen uns dass
doktor ihre noch zugeschaltet ist
facharzt für innere medizin und teil des
teams für infektiologie am uniklinikum
hamburg eppendorf
außerdem betreibt der infekt you brought
de einem podcast über
infektionskrankheiten dankeschön dass
sie dabei sind wir freude auf ihre und
eure fragen und kommentare wie immer in
die kommentare oder wenn ihr oder sie
die zdf- heute- app nutzt bitte an diese
e mail adresse hdr koch das ging und
geht jetzt ganz schön schnell geht ihnen
das zu schnell
nein mir geht das nicht so schnell ich
muss sagen die letzten wochen waren für
jemand der schon seit längerer zeit an
impfstoffen forscht und vor allem
impfstoffen zu neu auftretenden
infektionskrankheiten
doch sehr bemerkenswert weil das diese
neuartige impfstoffe jetzt wirklich so
hoch wirksam sind darin uns vor der
erkrankung mit 19 zu schützen
das hatten wir glaube ich in der
wissenschaftlichen community so nicht
erwartet und das waren wirklich sehr
positive nachrichten die ich das gehört
habe
und das stimmt die entwicklung von
diesen impfstoffen ist jetzt wirklich so
schnell gegangen wie das ist jetzt noch
nie stattgefunden hat und der
menschheitsgeschichte
aber das ist größtenteils ein
finanzielles risiko was da eingegangen
wurde da können wir vielleicht später
auch noch mal genauer drauf gucken genau
das werden wir tun und auch über die
vielen bedenken die wir auch hier in der
community haben viele kommentare gehen
schon in die richtung welche gefahren
stecken da drin ist es nicht doch zu
schnell
und wie sicher ist dieser impfstoff
dafür haben wir nachher sehr viel zeit
erst mal aber noch zu dir andreas wie
reagieren denn die briten euphorisch
erleichtert zurückhaltend ja ich glaube
vor allem das politische großbritannien
ist euphorisiert denn man darf nicht
vergessen der premierminister der
schwimmt hier der hat die ja die die
vielleicht in europa größte katastrophe
zu verantworten was die todeszahlen
angeht es sind mittlerweile über 60.000
und da reden wir nicht von der
dunkelziffer
und er hat vor allen dingen auch ein
wirtschaftseinbruch von minus elf
prozent zu verantworten für dieses für
dieses jahr und gestern hat seine
fraktion seine partei rebell ihr team
haben 60 abgeordnete die gefolgschaft
verweigert bei eigentlich dem was heute
eigentlich wirklich passieren sollte
nämlich dass hier der lockdown der etwas
kleinere lockdown der vier wochen hier
war der wurde aufgehoben und ein neues
system etabliert da wollten viele nicht
mit und für boris johnson war das heute
ein tag zum aufatmen denn dieses dieser
impfstoff der gibt ihm hoffnungen dass
er diese krise politisch meistern kann
daran dass du das jetzt schon sehr auf
die euphorie innerhalb der politik
beschränkt hast schließe ich jetzt mal
dass sie für stimmung in der bevölkerung
vielleicht eine andere ist darüber
kannst du uns vielleicht gleich nochmal
was erzählen aber wir schauen uns an wie
denn die britische politik diesen erfolg
wie sie ihn für sich verzeichnet heute
verkündet hat du hast dazu ein stück
gemacht wir schauen uns das an kleine
fläschchen mit viel hoffnung drin in
rekordzeit entwickelt und nun in
großbritannien in rekordzeit zugelassen
800.000 dosen des biotech kaiser
impfstoffs sind auf dem weg ins
königreich fantastische nachrichten so
der premier
durch den schutz von impfstoffen werden
wir letztlich wieder unser normales
leben führen können und der wirtschaft
auf die beine helfen
bewohner und pfleger in altenheimen über
80-jährige medizinisches personal haben
priorität stoff für millionen impfungen
soll schon ende des jahres bereitstehen
die unabhängige zulassungsbehörde
erklärt das beschleunigt den notfall
verfahren bedeutet keinesfalls weniger
sicherheitslecks der zugelassene
impfstoff erfüllt die strengsten
höchsten standards was sicherheit
wirksamkeit und qualität angeht die
sicherheit der bevölkerung war in diesem
verfahren immer das wichtigste für uns
offen bleibt wie großbritannien den
impfstoff wochen früher zu lassen kann
als etwa die eu arzneimittelbehörde klar
ist transport und verteilung erfordern
eine logistische meisterleistung nur bei
minus 70 grad hält sich der impfstoff
länger bei kühlschranktemperatur sind es
nur wenige tage
das militär soll helfen die zulassung
ist ein meilenstein im kampf gegen
korona aber nur einer auf einem
ansonsten noch langen weg
die aufnahme der bevölkerung dieser
nachricht wir haben die briten reagiert
natürlich ist da ist er freude da denn
dass man lange lockdown die hinter den
briten liegen und auch noch viele monate
in denen man weiß dass es eben weiter
beschränkungen gibt einschränkungen des
des lebens hier heute haben die pubs die
restaurants zum ersten mal wieder
aufgemacht und viele genießen das auch
aber man weiß natürlich dass viele
virologen waren und sagen den preis
dafür werden wir im januar und im
februar zahlen wenn wir jetzt
weihnachten feiern mit den familien wenn
wir jetzt öffnen
aber der britischen regierung boris
johnson blieb gar nichts anderes übrig
insofern freuen sich natürlich viele das
licht am ende des tunnels man hat
natürlich genauso wie in deutschland
viele fragen ist das sicher wie wann bin
ich dran denn das darf man auch nicht
vergessen es sind 800.000 dosen das
heißt 400.000 menschen können erst mal
geimpft werden in jeder braucht zwei
dosen und allein in der obersten
prioritäten gruppe die hier festgelegt
wurde also sondern die älteren ab 70 und
die die im medizinischen bereich
arbeiten oder in alten- und pflegeheim
die an eben auch die älteren
da braucht man 30 millionen impfungen
also 60 millionen dosen so viel hat man
gar nicht bestellt
das ist natürlich etwas die euphorie
aber es ist eben da anfangen
großbritannien hat auch wieder andere
staaten wie deutschland auch andere
impfstoffe eingekauft und wenn die alle
so erfolgreich sind wie das die die
arzneimittelzulassungsbehörde sagt dann
ist man einfach guter dinge
ich glaube dass wir sicherheit kann der
kollege der mit dabei ist mehr sagen als
virologe aber die haben heute schon klar
gemacht wir werden nicht das leben von
hunderttausenden briten oder deren
gesundheit aufs spiel setzen diese
prüfung war nach allen regeln der kunst
es gab keine short cuts keine
abkürzungen und darauf muss man sich
natürlich erstmal verlassen dann sage
ich modelle an dieser stelle vielen dank
andreas damm für diese eindrücke nach
london und andreas muss jetzt weiter an
anderer stelle arbeiten denn du musst
noch ein stück fürs journal machen und
für das update wenn ich richtig
informiert bin
deshalb sagen wir an dieser stelle
vielen da ich glaube da ging was dagegen
das durcheinander das macht mein kollege
ich würde gern weiter noch zu wenn ich
darf und was nicht und ich bin sehr
gespannt auch auf die auf die ausführung
des fachmanns ja umso besser dann danke
ich dir für ist in der kälte ausharren
und dann binden wir dich einfach wieder
ins gespräch mit ein und machen jetzt
tatsächlich mal weiter mit dem experten
den du gerade angesprochen hast denn
wenn ich mir hier die community angucke
dann ist tatsächlich die riesengroße
frage hat ob koch ist dieser wirkstoffe
dieser dieser impfstoff getestet ist er
so ausreichend getestet dass er sicher
ist dass man sich guten gewissens testen
lassen kann zum beispiel fragt über
youtube ein user namens beschränkte
sicht wurde der in stoffen ausreichend
an definierten risikogruppen getestet um
eine schadenfreie wirkung zu
gewährleisten
herr dr koch können sie uns kurz
erklären wie denn üblicherweise so ein
impfstoff getestet und zugelassen wird
und inwiefern denn auch risikogruppen in
diesen test verfahren überhaupt getestet
werden
genau vielleicht können wir es einmal
anschauen wie die impfstoffentwicklung
normalerweise funktioniert also die
impfstoffentwicklung gegen neu
auftretende viruserkrankungen
war sozusagen in den letzten jahren und
jahrzehnten vielleicht etwas hat etwas
zu wenig beachtung erfahren und das ist
glaube ich ein grund warum es jetzt auch
so schnell geht aber jetzt ganz
grundsätzlich funktioniert im stoff
entwicklung ja so dass jemand eine idee
hat etwas gegen eine erkrankung zu tun
zum beispiel und dann kommt es zunächst
in der präklinischen phase zu
entwicklungen und die präklinischen
phase meint dass es noch nicht im
menschen stattfindet sondern in der
zellkultur oder in den tierversuchen
meinetwegen meistens in den mäusen als
erstes mal
dann kommt irgendwann industriepartner
im spiel ins spiel und das ganze geht
weiter ist findet so prozess
definitionen stadt also das ganze
dieser impfstoff entwicklung muss dann
nach bestimmten maßstäben der qualität
gut meine factoring practice gmp sind
sagen wir dazu stattfinden ist müssen
toxikologische studien stattfinden und
so weiter und irgendwann kommt eben der
sprung in die klinische phase der
impfstoff entwicklung und da gibt es
dann eben diese drei stufen also auf
diese drei phasen der
impfstoffentwicklung das haben jetzt
glaube ich auch schon oft gehört die
phase 1 ist sozusagen die studien die
zum ersten mal den menschen stattfinden
da geht es primär um die sicherheit und
verträglichkeit der impfstoffe das sind
meistens wenige leute meistens unter 50
probanden und probanden die geimpft
werden und die werden erst mal
gestaffelt geimpft das heißt man fängt
erst mal mit einer person an
dann nimmt man zwei weitere und so
weiter und da ist wie gesagt der großer
fokus zu gucken ob der impfstoff sicher
und verträglich ist
in der zweiten phase der entwicklung
sind dann schon deutlich mehr
probandinnen involviert einige hundert
meistens und es geht primär um die dosis
findung das heißt man guckt sich zum
beispiel zwei oder drei verschiedene
dosierungen dämmstoffe an und probiert
da das optimale mittel zu finden aus
induzierter immunantwort also verursacht
dann schutz potenziell einerseits und
nebenwirkungen des impfstoffs
andererseits in der dritten phase und
das war eben die große phase über die
jetzt in den letzten wochen berichtet
wurde geht es dann über um die
überprüfung der wirksamkeit in deutsch
gibt es leider nur dieses wort
wirksamkeit in englisch unterscheidet
man auch ein bisschen die fixie das ist
wie gut der impfstoff in der studie
funktioniert und die effektiven ist das
ist dann wie gut der impfstoff im
wirklichen leben funktioniert aber im
prinzip geht es um die wirksamkeit der
stühle und das sind eben die studien die
jetzt zuletzt von den großen preis am
sonntag an die schon genannt aber auch
moderner
neben astrazeneca wichtig wurden ja da
fahren sie fort
genau und normalerweise dauert das eben
sehr lange und man kann sagen mindestens
zehn jahre eigentlich und das ist jetzt
so schnell gegangen ist das heißt dass
wir jetzt wirklich eine impfstoff
entwicklung mit wie sie gerade schon
gesagt habe deine ersten zur notfall
zulassung in großbritannien nach nur
zehn monaten hatten ist wirklich
außergewöhnlich und so noch nicht
dagewesen das ist muss man wirklich auch
betonen und das ist aber etwas positives
denn diese entwicklung die ich gerade
skizziert habe mit den präklinischen
phasen und dann den verschiedenen phasen
der klinischen impfstoffentwicklung das
ist in der regel zumindest für industrie
hersteller mit einem enormen
finanziellen risiko vergesellschaftet
denn es kann immer sein dass irgendeinem
diese dieser zeitpunkt in der
impfstoffentwicklung das ganz
abgebrochen werden muss und man das
ganze projekt quasi einstampfen muss und
dann als impfstoff entwickler die vielen
millionen die da rein geflossen sind
verloren hat und der hauptunterschied zu
der jetzigen situation der weltweiten
pandemie war
man kann sagen dass das geld eigentlich
keine rolle gespielt hat und dass das
vor allem auch die impfstoffentwicklung
nicht verzögert hat sondern es wurde
jetzt im prinzip ab januar oder februar
nicht nur mit der entwicklung von dieser
in impfstoffen begonnen sondern eben
auch mit der produktion und zwar mit der
produktion einen richtig großen stil und
das ist etwas was zu normalen nicht
pandemie zeiten gewissermaßen
unternehmen unternehmerische selbstmord
gewesen wäre und das hätte vorher nie
jemand gemacht und nur weil jetzt so
viel geld und ressourcen im spiel waren
war das überhaupt möglich dass man jetzt
nicht nur diese studien so rasch
vorangetrieben hat sondern jetzt auch
schon impfstoffe hat weil normalerweise
musste man natürlich auch erste
wirksamkeit demonstrieren in der
impfstoffentwicklung und dann fing
überhaupt die produktion an
darf ich da mal kurz rein grätschen denn
man kann sich ja mit geld vieles kaufen
aber zeit eben nicht und zeit braucht
man natürlich auch um herauszufinden
welche langzeitfolgen solche impfungen
haben oder welche nebenwirkungen sie
haben
wie reagieren sie denn darauf genau also
die große der große kritische die groß
kritische hürde die in der
impfstoffentwicklung genommen werden
muss ist eben diese ganz entscheidende
phase drei worum mehrere zehntausende
freiwillige
getestet werden und komischerweise oder
vielleicht auch tragischerweise gegen
diese phase 3 impfstoff studien jetzt
besonders schnell weil eben wir diese
zweite welle weltweit von der sa skoff
zwei pandemie erlebt haben weil die
phase 3 ist eine studie wo ich leute mit
dem placebo oder mit dem währung also
mit dem richtigen impfstoff impfen und
dann gucke wie viele infizieren sich in
der einen und in der anderen gruppe und
werden es nur insgesamt weltweit ganz
ganz wenige infektionen gibt dann kann
ich das natürlich schlecht überprüfen
weil sich dann niemand infiziert
aber er hat ja die situation dass es
dramatisch infektionszahlen überall gibt
und das ist auch ein grund warum diese
phase 3 studien jetzt so schnell
abgeschlossen werden konnten sollen
jetzt schon zu den großen themen gebiet
der nebenwirkungen kommen das können wir
auch sehr gerne darüber reden ja das
könnten wir gerne machen ich würde nur
gerne vorher noch einen eine kritische
stimme mit einbeziehen und zwar hat sich
wolf dieter ludwig geäußert er ist
vorsitzender der arzneimittelkommission
der deutschen ärzteschaft und herr
professor ludwig hat vor einer schnellen
zulassung der impfstoffe gewarnt aus
verschiedenen gründen
und da würde ich wenn das technisch
möglich ist gerne mal reinhören denn
gerade die frage warum es so schnell
geht
die beschäftigt tatsächlich viele und
danach sprechen wir über die
nebenwirkungen
sie haben es damals hendrix gesehen dem
impfstoff gegen die schweinegrippe
wissen dass die langzeitsicherheit
aufgrund der sehr beschleunigten
verfahren die auch notwendig waren vor
dem hintergrund der pandemie durchaus
gravierende nebenwirkungen auftreten
können ich darf daran erinnern dass wir
mit diesen beiden ersten boten rna im
stoff noch ein neues gebiet betreten das
gab es ja keine impfstoffe die mit
dieser technologie hergestellt wurden
das heißt wir können die
langzeitsicherheit derzeit definitiv
nicht beurteilen wir wissen in
deutschland aufgrund aktueller umfragen
dass derzeit vielleicht etwa 50% sich
impfen lassen wollen
das heißt damit werden wir keine erden
immunität erzielen und damit werden wir
mit der pandemie noch sehr lange zu tun
haben wenn wir jetzt etwas länger warten
würden die informationen aus den studien
die den zulassungsbehörden vorliegen
auch den verantwortlichen ärzten und
ärzte mitteilen dann hätten wir
sicherlich eine größere sicherheit
dieses wichtige ziel der pandemie
bekämpfung zu erreichen
herr doktor kocht das ist ja wenn man
das hört keine grundsätzliche ablehnung
der impfung überhaupt gar nicht im
gegenteil aber es ist eben ein plädoyer
für mehr informationen und auch für mehr
zeit weil er professor ludwig sagt die
langzeitsicherheit kann man im moment
noch nicht beurteilen was würden sie da
entgegnen genau der kollege hat ein paar
gute punkte gemacht das eine ist dass
wir die daten noch nicht haben und das
stimmt das ist sind im moment diese
pressemitteilung die wir gehört haben im
november das sind noch keine durch den
peer review gelaufen wirklich
publikation das heißt die daten haben
wir de facto noch nicht gesehen
es gibt aber jetzt aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht keinen großen
grund da wirklich daran zu zweifeln
zumindest an den daten die die
hersteller von den m rna impfstoffen da
jetzt verlautbart haben aber das ist
sicherlich so um dass wirklich
beurteilen zu können müssen wir also
nicht nur die zulassungsbehörden sondern
auch wir in der wissenschaftlichen
community natürlich die daten sehen da
hat er vollkommen recht ruhig ein
bisschen widersprechen muss ist bei der
aussage dass es noch nie m rna
impfstoffe menschen getestet worden sein
das hört man immer auch im fernsehen das
stimmt so oder einfach nicht es wurde
natürlich noch nie ein mrsa impfstoff
gegen saas kauf zwei im menschen
getestet das kann ja auch nicht sein
weil die jetzt gerade erst entwickelt
worden sind
aber das feld der rna impfstoffe ist
eines wohl schon viel forschung in den
letzten jahren und jahrzehnten daran
stattgefunden hat das hat ungefähr 1990
er jahren angefangen und der kollege
florian kramer mal so eine ganz schöne
tabelle zusammengestellt da geht
durchaus daraus hervor
das ist es einige hundert können die
tabelle zeigen ja wir bekommen die wir
haben die hier vorliegen
das ist allerdings eine von denen von
den tabellen die man tatsächlich
erklären muss man kann sie nachsehen in
der timeline von florian kramer über
über twitter ich weiß nicht sie können
sich vielleicht jetzt selber gar nicht
sehen aber wir haben sie hier vorliegen
könnte ganz kurz erklären was das aus
sagt genau also der hat einfach mal
aufgeschrieben wo im bereich der
infektionserkrankungen welche
klinischen studien also studien die
einen impfstoffkandidaten testen
durchgeführt wurden in den letzten
jahren von impfstoffkandidaten die eben
auf messenger rna technologie basieren
das sind jetzt noch längst nicht alle
studien weil es gibt auch noch andere
felder in denen intensiv an impfstoffen
geforscht wird zb das feld der
krebsforschung also cancers 1 die
versuchen auch therapeutische vakzine
also impfstoffe dann meistens
herzustellen aber nehmen wir mal das was
jetzt aus infektionserkrankung trials
bekannt ist und da sieht man dass es
zumindest einige hundert individuen in
diese studien immer eingeschlossen sind
und dass die zum teil auch schon viele
jahre zurück liegen dass diese studien
begonnen wurden das heißt da haben wir
jetzt nicht viele tausende probandinnen
und probanden aber es ist zumindest
nicht ganz richtig zu sagen dass diese
technologie noch nie im menschen
getestet wurde
was stimmt ist zum beispiel also ich
sehe hier 2013 2014 sind so die
frühesten jahre die hier in der tabelle
aufteilung und hier sehen wir was die
probanden angeht bei moderner sind es
zum beispiel 452 das ist jetzt hier die
höchste zahl die in gerne genannt wird
ja genau das ist jetzt nicht
vergleichbar mit den derzeitigen studien
weil das eben auch keine phase 3 studien
waren und dieses impfstoffkandidaten
dann sieht man eben auch dass die
entwicklung gegen infektionserkrankungen
also die entwicklung von impfstoffen
nicht besonders schnell vorangegangen
ist in den letzten jahrzehnten
das ist schade ich würde mir wünschen
dass das als eine lehre aus dieser
pandemie jetzt schneller geht aber so
war es nun mal in der letzten zeit
dann können wir genau an dieser stelle
vielleicht ganz gut mal darauf eingehen
wie die vorbehalte gegen diese m rna
impfungen sind da gibt es zum beispiel
die frage von detective es besteht die
möglichkeit dass dieser neue impfstoff
noch einiger zeit möglicherweise zwei
bis drei jahre tumore auslösen und krebs
erzeugen kann
wie sieht es mit der potenz oder anderen
langzeitfolgen aus genau also vorbei den
dna basierten impfstoff und hört man ja
immer wieder dass die gefahr bestünde
dass sie sich in das genom integrieren
und da muss man sagen das ist biologisch
nicht möglich eigentlich eine in der
biologie für die die bio studiert haben
oder medizin die wissen dass es in der
zelle gewissermaßen eine einbahnstraße
gibt wir haben in dem zellkern
doppelsträngige dna die wird
umgeschrieben in die messenger rna die
wird dann aus dem zellkern
heraustransportiert in das zu tun also
in den rest von der zelle und dort dann
in protein umgeschrieben und das heißt
diese abfolge von dna aus dna wird er
dann aus rna mit protein und das protein
zum beispiel dass bei protein erscheint
dann auf der oberfläche der zelle und
macht eine wirkung
das ist eine einbahnstraße und das kann
nicht umgedreht werden das heißt wenn
jetzt rna in eine menschliche zelle
kommt und das kommt sie zb diese durch
diese impfung das kommt sie aber auch
durch bei der virusinfektion weil auch
wenn man mit sauerstoff 2 infiziert wird
machen ja viren genau dass viren dringen
in die zellen ein und benutzten die
maschinerie der zelle um ihre eigene
renate einzuschleusen das heißt auch bei
einer infektion wird massenweise wie
nach der impfung dieses protein
exprimiert
aber das heißt dass ich das in die dna
integriert und da irgendwelche schäden
macht wie die die sie gerade genannt
haben
das geht so zu einem biologisch nicht
ffm
alex 89 fragt auf youtube welchen
nebenwirkungen gibt es und wie sind die
exakten prozentwerte der verschiedenen
neben wirkungsgrade leichte mittlere und
schwere jetzt fürchte ich dass sie das
so genau nicht beantworten können eben
weil die daten wie gerade schon genannt
auch nicht vorliegen wenn ja umso besser
und da ist sie tatsächlich die frage
nach den nebenwirkungen
genau dann da auch das ist etwas
komplexes thema da müssen jetzt mal ein
bisschen rein einsteigen das finde ich
aber gut weil das ist ja etwas was die
leute wirklich auch bewegt also wenn man
in klinischen studien impfstoff getestet
dann ist gerade in den früheren phasen
sind die nebenwirkungen super
entscheidend aber eben auch in der phase
3 oder auch in der phase 4 nach der
zulassung sind die nebenwirkungen total
wichtig dass man die untersucht und man
kann grob unterscheiden einmal in so
genannte serious adverse event also
schwerwiegende impfnebenwirkungen das
was man auf jeden fall vermeiden würde
was man nicht will dass das in dem
impfstoff vorkommt und dann in so
genannten on es also die nicht ganz so
schwerwiegenden schweregrade
und die letzteren kann man wiederum in
110 grad eins bis drei vielleicht
einteilen und in bei den impfstoffen die
wir von dem wir bis jetzt in den letzten
wochen gehört haben sind keine es also
keine dieser schwerwiegenden
nebenwirkungen eingetreten und man muss
bei nebenwirkungen generell
unterscheiden einerseits zwischen
reaktor genäht und dann das was man dass
man vielleicht unter schwerwiegenden
impfschäden immer so ich will zunächst
mal auf das erste eingehen reaktivität
ist sind reaktionen die man bei den
allermeisten impfungen hat und das sind
reaktionen die in den ersten wenigen
tagen nach impfungen auftritt was sind
das jetzt für sachen das sind zum
beispiel schmerzen an der einstichstelle
das sind kopfschmerzen das ist müdigkeit
leicht erhöhte temperaturen und
muskelschmerzen und das ist auch nicht
ungewöhnlich dass das nach einer impfung
auftritt weil das was die impfung macht
ist ja dass sie dem körper gewissermaßen
eine immunreaktion vorgaukelt und wenn
ich eine immunreaktion in mir ausgelöst
wird weil ich zb mit einem virus
infiziert werde
springt so kann man vielleicht sagen
mein immunsystem an und er schüttet
stoffe aus die wir interferone nennen
und die wird man die gibt es in einigen
ganz seltenen erkrankungen auch als
medikament und die machen genau diese
nebenwirkungen die wir gerade
beschrieben haben das heißt die lassen
mich so fühlen dass es mir wie bei einer
grippe geht zum beispiel also dass ich
muskelschmerzen habe dass ich vielleicht
leicht erhöhte temperaturen haben usw
usw
und es entsteht natürlich auch eine
lokale reaktion also an der stelle wo
ich wirklich geimpft worden bin das tut
weh das kann auch mal rot werden und so
weiter diese ganzen symptome nicht
genannt habe von der reaktivität treten
häufig auf ich denke wir kennen das alle
wenn wir mal gegen grippe geimpft worden
sind oder gegen tetanus zum beispiel
aber auch nicht bei allen ergeben
das muss man sagen bei den m rna
impfstoffen nach den daten die wir bis
jetzt gesehen haben tritt das etwas
häufiger auf als bei anderen impfungen
das heißt sie machen eine etwas stärkere
reaktor genäht das wussten wir auch
schon aus den phase eins und zwei
studien da hat sich das auch gezeigt und
auch in den tiermodellen also wenn man
die impfstoffe zum beispiel an affen
getestet hat dann hat man das auch
gesehen dass sie eine relativ hohe
reaktivität haben ich selber finde das
immer gar nicht so schlecht in der
empfängt
impfstoff entwicklung weil man kann
vielleicht sagen wenn man eine hohe
reaktivität hat dann hat man in der
regel auch eine hohe immunantwort und
eine gute immunantwort und damit dann
potenziell auch einen guten schutz
das heißt wenn wir jetzt eine impfung
hätten von der man gar nichts merkt und
wo es gar keinen unterschied zu der
impfung mit placebo also mit einer
kochsalzlösung gibt dann würde ich
denken okay das wäre eine impfung die
vielleicht nicht sondern ganz vorn
schutzmacht und bei den impfungen die
wir kennen zum beispiel gegen gelbfieber
oder gegen masern also impfungen die zu
den besten gehören die wir kennen wo ein
oder zweimalige impfung eigentlich einen
lebenslangen schutz machen ist das auch
so dass die mit einer gewissen
reaktivität einhergehen aber wie gesagt
diese nebenwirkungen sind alle transient
also die gehen schnell vorbei nach 24
oder spätestens 48 stunden
aber ich finde eben auch wichtig die
leute die man jetzt darauf hinzuweisen
dass sind die symptome die ihr erwarten
könnte eigentlich nur dann würde ich
gerne von dem komplex der nebenwirkungen
mal zum komplex der wirksamkeit des
impfstoffes kommen dann auch dazu fragen
viele user die fragen würde ich gerne
gleich nochmal aufdröseln aber wie ist
die immunität wie lange hält das an wie
oft musste ich mich impfen lassen
und dazu haben wir in kurzen einspieler
mit der großen überschrift bedeutet ist
wenn die impfung da ist dass wir unser
normales leben wieder haben
kommt sofort dauert ein bisschen aber
kommt bedeutet ein impfstoff das ende
der pandemie klare antwort zumindest
erstmal nein eben weil zunächst nicht
genügend impfdosen für alle da sein
werden und auch weil bisher noch nicht
klar ist ob geimpfte das virus trotz der
impfung noch weiter an andere menschen
übertragen können
trotzdem
der impfstoff wird schon am schluss das
letzte teilchen sein was uns aus dieser
hölle erlösen wird ich glaube man muss
sich aber auch darüber klar sein dass es
nicht von heute auf morgen passieren
werde
und so werden wir noch eine weile mit
corona leben müssen selbst wenn die
zulassung von impfstoffen auch in
deutschland immer näher rückt
herr dr tochter fragt zum beispiel mehr
längen über youtube ist nach der impfung
eine immunität wirklich zu 100 prozent
gesichert
also in der medizin ist ja nicht
irgendetwas zu 100 prozent gesichert
deswegen nein auf jeden fall nicht aber
wir können uns ja mal angucken was diese
ersten verlautbarungen diese
pressemitteilung vor allem der firma der
firmenfeier biontech dann moderner und
eben astrazeneca und der uni von oxford
was die denn was das denn eigentlich
sind weil in der phase 3 impfstoff
studien läuft das so dass man so etwas
macht was man geplante interimsanalyse
nennt bei dem fall auch moderner studien
war es ja zum beispiel so dass über
40.000 probandinnen geimpft worden sind
und ich hatte das vorhin schon gesagt
die sind nicht alle mit dem richtigen
impfstoff also mit dem währungen impft
worden sondern etwa die hälfte ist auch
mit einem placebo kämpft vorne und dass
es eben ganz wichtig um diese
effektivität beurteilen zu können
und die haben jetzt schon im vorhinein
in ihre studienprotokolle
reingeschrieben das ist immer ganz
wichtig um sozusagen die
wissenschaftliche güte von so einem
prozess hinter wirklich auch beurteilen
zu können haben die auf jeden fall rein
geschrieben wenn wir eine bestimmte
anzahl von infektionen mit 19 an den
studienteilnehmer in registrieren dann
wollen wir einmal aufdecken und gucken
wie viele von denen waren jetzt in dem
placebo arm und wie viele waren in dem
wir umarmen und bei der aktuellen
interimsanalyse von der firma moderner
zum beispiel haben sie das gemacht
nachdem sie 196 infektionen mit
sauerstoff 2 die auch symptomatisch
waren also kommt 19 erkrankungen
registriert haben und haben dann geguckt
wie viel sind davon im placebo arm und
wie viele sind davon im währung am und
da waren eben 94 mw im placebo arm und
eben nur ein ganz kleiner teil war in
dem roman also es haben viel weniger
leute mit 19 bekommen die den impfstoff
wirklich bekommen haben und viel mehr 19
bekommen die vorher die placebo
injektion
wie ist das denn mit der frage ob man
infektiös ist wenn man geimpft ist also
mann erkrankt zwar nicht aber die frage
ob man trotz impfung das virus weiter
geben kann die ist wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe noch nicht beantwortet
ja das finde ich super dass sie das
ansprechen das geht mir auch immer ein
bisschen zu kommen etwas zu wenig in der
berichterstattung vor das ist eine ganz
wichtige unterscheidung es geht ja
einerseits um den schutz den die impfung
vermitteln kann vor der erkrankung 19
und zum anderen eben um den schutz vor
der eventuell symptomatischen infektion
mit sauerstoff 2 und man kann vielleicht
und dann gibt's noch eine dritte sache
nämlich den schutz nicht nur vor der
normalen kurve 19 erkrankungen sondern
vielleicht vor der schweren kurve 19
erkrankungen kann vielleicht das so
sagen dass es für den der
impfstoffherstellung am oder entwicklung
am leichtesten ist leute vor einem
schweren krankheitsverlauf zu schützen
etwas schwerer ss leute vor einem
normalen krankheitsverlauf zu schützen
und ganz schwer es ist wirklich so etwas
wie eine sterile immunität herzustellen
so dass man sich auch gar nicht mehr
infizieren kann mit dem virus
wir kennen das von anderen impfstoffen
beispielsweise von dem polier aktien
also gegen kinderlähmung da gibt es
einiges was man den muskel spritzt das
schützt uns zu 100 prozent gegen der eg
vor der erkrankung und es gibt ein
anderes was man als schluckimpfung
nehmen kann
das macht ein sogenannter sterilisieren
der immunität also eine stille freyung
hat man doch früher zugesagt da kann ich
mich dann auch wirklich gar nicht erst
infizieren mit dem virus
und genau da aber jetzt ihre frage ob
die die jetzigen studien dass auch
untersuchen das tun sie nicht also die
untersuchung nur ob die impfstoffe nicht
für mich vor kurt 19 also vor der
erkrankung schützen und das ist auch
verständlich weil diese infektionsschutz
also ob ich mich auch vor der
symptomatischen infektion mit salz kopf
zwei schützen kann das ist deutlich
schwerer zu überprüfen und müsste er
kann sich ja vorstellen müsste dann im
prinzip alle von den zehntausenden die
da teilnehmen dauer also regelmäßig alle
soundsoviel tage vielleicht abstreichen
das ist deutlich aufwendiger und ich
finde es sozusagen auch in ordnung dass
das jetzt erst mal nur fokussiert wurde
diese studien auf schutz vor der
erkrankung
das würde ja natürlich bedeuten dass
wenn die leute sich impfen lassen das
virus sich zwar weiter ausbreitet aber
eben die schweren verläufe damit
verhindert werden könnten und das ist ja
das genau was diese pandemie so
schwierig macht dass man versuchen muss
die intensivstationen freizuhalten und
schwere verläufe eben zu verhindern
und das würde durch diese impfung wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe
wenn sich denn viele impfen lassen und
wenn vor allem wohl mehr abele gruppen
und ältere menschen sich impfen lassen
verhindert werden genau
also sie haben schon angesprochen das
sind genau die beiden gruppen die wir
impfen müssen einmal die vor allem
wollen radeln also primär ältere leute
und dann natürlich leute die es leicht
weitergeben können und dies vor allem
leicht weitergeben können an eben die
erstgenannten wohlen rebellengruppen
ich glaube es sind auch entsprechende
überlegungen dass die allerersten die
geimpft werden sollen alte leute in den
pflegeheimen sind und aber auch die
kolleginnen und kollegen die in den
pflegeheimen arbeiten und diese leute
eben betreuen weil die natürlich auch
sich nicht infizieren sollen um die
nicht so anzustellen
nun haben wir hier zwei user fragen aus
dieser gruppe der risikopatienten die
möchte ich gerne an sie weitergeben eva
tofalvi schreibt über youtube meine
lungenfunktion ist eingeschränkt bekomme
ich als risikopatient recht zügig die
impfung und der zweite möchte ich gerne
anschließend per mail fragt claudia
brunner ich möchte gerne ihre
einschätzung zur auswirkung des
wirkstoffs auf vorhandene
autoimmunkrankheiten erfahren ich habe
multiple sklerose und mache mir
natürlich gedanken ob ein impfstoff der
auf die aktivierung des immunsystems
zielt bei autoimmunkrankheiten wie ms
schübe verursachen kann
genau das sind das sind wichtige fragen
also was in der impfstoffforschung ein
problem bei älteren leuten ist ist nicht
so sehr dass die stärkere nebenwirkungen
kriegen oder eine stärkere immunantwort
sondern eher das gegenteil
das heißt das problem was wir zum
beispiel bei der influenza impfung haben
jetzt dass ältere leute da eine höhere
dosis benötigen weil sie per se einen
vielleicht eine weniger gute
immunantwort machen da gibt es so ein
phänomen das nennt man immun seneszenz
also das ist das immunsystem ein wenig
schwächer vielleicht wird im alter so
könnte man sagen genau das heißt das
würde ich nicht befürchten dass ältere
leute oder auch leute mit
vorerkrankungen jetzt stärker auf diesen
impfstoff reagieren
ob jetzt so eine
bei multipler sklerose speziell dieser
impfstoff zu einer aktivierung führt das
kann man mit 100 prozentiger sicherheit
jetzt sicherlich noch nicht sagen
es wäre aber doch sehr ungewöhnlich weil
wir natürlich bei ms-patienten patienten
schon viele erfahrungen mit impfungen
haben und so genannte tod impfungen also
impfungen die nur erreger bruchstücke
enthalten und eben keine lebenden viren
die sind auch für ms-patienten patienten
eigentlich ungefährlich im gegenteil
gehen wollen wir ja eigentlich dass sich
leute mit ms auch beispielsweise gegen
tetanus impfen
genau bei lebend impfung ist es ein
bisschen was anderes aber das sind jetzt
ja alles keine lebend impfung batterien
eine frage würde ich gerne auch
anschließend tom erfragt reicht eine
impfung oder muss diese wiederholt
werden und wenn ja in welchem abstand
ja genau das ist auch eine sehr wichtige
frage bei den allermeisten dieser
impfung haben wir zwei dosierungen die
unterscheiden sich so ein klein bisschen
von der reihenfolge bei kaiser ist es so
dass am tag 0 21 also nach drei wochen
die zweite impfung die so genannte
booster impfung stattfindet bei den
meisten anderen studien moderne aber
auch astrazeneca ist es so dass nach
vier wochen ungefähr gepustet wird das
kann auch gut sein dass da in den
nächsten monaten und vielleicht auch
jahren das daran noch ein bisschen
gedreht wird das heißt dass man versuche
macht genau herauszufinden was ist der
optimale abstand oder kann ich
vielleicht auch diese verschiedenen
impfstoffe vielleicht auch kombinieren
es gibt einen impfstoff der hat noch
keine der läuft gerade die phase 3
studie von der firma johnson & johnson
das ist auch ein adenovirus basierter
vector impfstoff der untersuch
tatsächlich nur eine impfdosis das ist
schon wissenschaftlich gesehen finde ich
ganz spannend weil das natürlich
logistisch einen riesen unterschied
macht ob ich nur eine impfstoffdosis
oder ob ich zwei verwenden muss um
jemanden da vor der erkrankung zu
schützen und das wäre natürlich viel
besser wenn man eine impfung hätte die
das auch mit einer impfdosis schaffen
würde dann würde ich gerne zum ende hin
noch einmal versuchen den kollegen
andreas stammen aus london mit ins boot
zu holen wenn er denn noch da ist und in
der kälte ausgeharrt hat er ist dann
doch andreas wir gucken gleich mal auf
die zahlen wie hoch die zustimmung hier
unter den befragten des politbarometers
ist wie viele sich denn impfen lassen
würden
hast du aus dem stand eine zahl wie hoch
die impfbereitschaft der briten ist
wie viele sind bereit sich gegen korona
impfen zu lassen
ja das variiert ein bisschen aber ich
glaube es ist ein wenig höher sind als
in deutschland so zwei drittel immer ein
bisschen davon ab wie man fragt aber ich
glaube die impfgegner sind in
deutschland etwas prominenter oder die
die sich davor
davor fürchten oder die die fragen
nahmen aber man muss sagen wenn ich eben
die fragen gehört habe vor allen dingen
von den zuschauer und zuschauerinnen
dann waren das ähnliche fragen die mir
heute hier auf bbc radio oder auf
anderen quellen von den briten und
britinnen entgegenkamen also das sind
das sind schon ähnliche bedenken aber es
sind auch sagen wir mal ähnliche fragen
aber dann doch auch viele die sagen na
ja da ist was da wird was getan da ist
etwas auch geschaffen von von
wissenschaftler von forschern das echt
erstaunlich ist und das kann uns helfen
diese pandemien griff zu kriegen denn
niemand auch hier glaubt dass das jetzt
außer die allergrößten optimisten dass
das jetzt im frühjahr vorbei sondern
alle haben auch darauf hingewiesen
masken tragen abstand halten also die
regeln die wir jetzt hoffentlich alle
verinnerlicht haben das muss weitergehen
denn so schnell geht das ganze nicht
also ich glaube ihre bereitschaft ist
ein wenig höher
aber es gibt auch hier skeptiker und die
tummeln sich natürlich vor allen dingen
auch auf twitter und facebook und da war
heute auch eine menge los aber ich
glaube viele menschen sind bereit und es
gab auch unglaublich viele freiwillige
die ihr teilgenommen haben die sich
gemeldet haben für die studie von
astrazeneca dem oxford wachsen also da
war eine hohe bereitschaft und ich
glaube das spiegelt sich dann auch
wieder aber man weiß im 75 80 prozent
müssen es sein für die berühmte
herdenimmunität ob das erreicht wird das
wenn wir dann vielleicht im nächsten
jahr frühestens sehen ja dann schauen
wir mal du hast gesagt es ist
wahrscheinlich ähnlich wie in
deutschland und das sieht so aus wir
gucken uns mal hier gerade auf meinem
laptop die zahlen vom politbarometer an
da wurde zum einen gefragt mit impfstoff
bis sommer ein weitgehend normales leben
wieder möglich sein
40 prozent der befragten glauben jahr 55
glauben nein und die frage ob sie sich
impfen lassen werden haben 51 prozent
mit ja beantwortet 29 prozent sind noch
unsicher und 20 prozent haben nein
gesagt herr dr koch noch einmal zu ihnen
wie viel prozent müssten sich impfen
lassen um diese herdenimmunität zu
erreichen die andreas stamm gerade
genannt hat sind dass auch diese 60 70
prozent aus ihrer sicht die man
erreichen müsste ja genau die herren den
wir uns jetzt so genau kann das niemand
im moment sagen man kann so ganz grob
sagen das ist schon mal sehr gut wäre
wenn sich zwei drittel der bevölkerung
impfen lassen würden und eine immunität
ausgebaut gebildet haben weil es geht ja
nicht darum dass man dieses virus
eliminiert das muss man sich auch klar
machen weil menschen sie ja nicht die
einzigen lebewesen die sich mit dem
virus infizieren können dann heißt das
kassiert bereits auch in
tierpopulationen und das ist völlig klar
dass wir das co2 nie wieder loswerden
sondern das virus wird bleiben sozusagen
die und deswegen ist es eben auch nicht
schwarz und weiß wir können das nicht
eliminieren sondern es geht eben darum
dass die tief in neue incidents zahlen
drastisch zurückgehen und das ist dann
vielleicht ein virus unter vielen wird
weil es gibt natürlich noch andere
atemwegserkrankungen wären aber die
treffen eben im moment nicht auf eine
naive population und laufen da wie wild
vor sozusagen durch ne genau dass die
herren anonymität kann sich kann
aufgebaut werden mit der zeit wenn wir
noch leute geben vielleicht zwei drittel
aber das wird jetzt nicht von heute auf
morgen die alleinige erlösung bringt
andreas hier kommen noch zwei fragen an
dich nach nach england und zwar fragt
per e mail
thomas sand wieso spricht man immer von
notfall zulassung
meines erachtens kann es doch nur so
sein dass der impfstoff zugelassen oder
eben nicht zugelassen wird also wieso
wird nur eine notfall zulassung
beantragt von den herstellern das ist
eine frage und die andere ist wieder von
ff mail 689 wird es eine impfpflicht in
großbritannien geben also die zweite
frage ist ganz einfach zu beantworten
auf gar keinen fall
da denkt hier niemand dran und schon gar
nicht boris johnson also der glaube ich
für solche ideen man kann halten von ihm
was man will
überhaupt nichts übrig hat und zu der
frage warum notfall zulassung naja ich
glaube dass es einfach ab gekürzt worden
also man hat er jetzt eigentlich nur
nebenwirkungen und und sonstiges
beobachtet über zwei monate und
normalerweise ist der zeitraum
mindestens sechs monate doch noch viel
länger es sind ja zehn jahre die oft
eine impfstoff entwicklung dauert hier
in zehn monaten
das heißt man hat abgekürzt im sinne von
weil man sagt die meisten also so habe
ich es heute verstanden die meisten
nebenwirkungen in den ersten zwei
monaten und das reicht uns hier jetzt
erst mal die daten die sie vorgelegt
wurden so hat das dass die
arzneimittelbehörde heute in einer
langen pressekonferenz dargelegt die
sind so überzeugend dass man sagt das
können wir riskieren das ist unterhalb
der schwelle dessen was wir verantworten
können und ich glaube man muss da diesen
experten folgen das ist ein unabhängiges
gremium und die haben immer wieder
deutlich gemacht mehrmals in dieser
presse kommen wollen sie wissen
natürlich dass es da bedenken gibt dass
hat hier keine abkürzung genommen und
wir spielen nicht mit der gesundheit von
100000 briten denn das sind auch unsere
freunde das sind noch unsere verwandten
das ist auch unsere familie und das sind
hier nicht irgendwelche dahergelaufenen
die jetzt hier
sagen wir mal unheil über das land
bringen wollen das muss man glaube ich
schon sagen insofern ist es eine notfall
zulassung wenn man das verfahren
abgekürzt hat aber eben im bewusstsein
oder in der hoffnung oder vielleicht
auch in der berechtigten hoffnung wenn
man die daten ausgewertet hat die ja
dieser kommission dann zur verfügung
stehen die uns und vielen
wissenschaftlern noch nicht zur
verfügung stehen und wie sie sich sicher
es ist sicher sicher genug andreas
vielen dank für diese einschätzungen und
dann würde ich gerne noch eine letzte
frage an herrn dr koch stellen nämlich
von auch über youtube not dead
unterstrich inside sollte man sich
lieber früh impfen lassen oder ein jahr
warten also da ja wir vorhin schon
gesagt haben vor allem risikogruppen
ältere und aber auch mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter im gesundheitsbereich
geimpft werden kann man sich das glaube
ich oft nicht so richtig aussuchen ich
würde mich eher früh impfen lassen
wollen weil es ist ja letztlich eine
risikoabwägung man muss abwägen das
risiko der kollege hat gerade genau
richtig gesagt ist ja im notfall zu
lassen also einerseits das risiko einer
virus infektion von den spätschäden der
virusinfektion oder eben auch an dem
virus zu sterben auf der anderen seite
jedoch nach den bisherigen daten sehr
überschaubaren risiken die es bei den
impfstoffen gibt und da würde für mich
auf jeden fall die waage in richtung der
impfung ausfallen
also ich würde mich verlassen vielen
dank für dieses statement vielen dank
für die wissenschaftliche einschätzung
und expertise und erklärung an sie heute
abend danke auch nochmal an andreas damm
nach london und ganz herzlichen dank an
sie und euch für die vielen vielen
konstruktiven fragen und kommentare
verzeiht es uns dass wir nicht alles
unter gekriegt haben das denn nicht alle
fragen beantworten konnten aber das war
ganz sicher nicht der letzte live stream
zum thema corona impfstoff in diesem
sinne bis bald
[Musik]